Blue Zones areas are populations around
the world where people live longest it
began with a 10-year project with
National Geographic to identify these
pockets where people are either reaching
age 100 at the highest rates they have
the highest life expectancy or the
lowest rate of middle-aged mortality
they're geographically defined and then
demographically confirmed and we found
five blue zones we found our first blue
zone in Sardinia Italy up in the
highlands the Laurel and Olli hasta
austra provinces and there we see a
population of about 42,000 people living
in 14 villages and theirs were the men
live the longest
normally in first world populations like
the United States for every one male
centenarian there are five female
centenarians but up in the highlands of
Sardinia the proportion is one to one
our second blue zone we found in Okinawa
Japan longest live women in the world
highest life expectancy of any other
population on earth they live about
eight years longer than American women
largely devoid of heart disease and the
cancers that kill us one of the more
extraordinary blue zones in khadiyah
Greece off the coast of Turkey 99 square
miles they live about seven years longer
than the average American but most
interestingly they almost completely
elude dementia we found almost everybody
over 70 on the island and found only
three mild cases that dementia in
America with a similar population you'd
expect to find somewhere around 20 to 40
percent people were suffering from
dementia then in Latin America the
Nicoya Peninsula of Costa Rica and then
finally in the United States the the
longest lived populations among the
seventh-day adventists in Loma Linda
California and they live up to a decade
longer than their North American
counterparts so I spend 10 years
traveling to these Blue Zones around the
world trying to explain why they're
living so long and I realized at about
year six that none of these spry
centenarians ever said to themselves at
age 50 well go darn it I'm going to get
on that longevity die and live another
50 years they never bought treadmills
they never caught called an 800 number
to buy
supplement longevity happened to them in
other words it was something that ensued
from their environment as opposed to
something they tried for first of all
they were eating a lot a high
carbohydrate diet about 65% of their
dietary intake came from carbs most of
those of course are whole grains or
beans beans is the cornerstone of every
longevity diet in the world about a cup
of beans a day about 20% of their
dietary intake was fats and most of
those were vegetable fats and about 15%
were proteins they did eat meat on
average about five times per month so
not a lot of meat it's mostly
plant-based diet about 90% overall of
their calories came from plants they
tended to eat up a huge breakfast
breakfast like a king lunch like a
prince and dinner like a pauper nuts
were the universal snack people eat a
handful of nuts with 2 to 3 years longer
than people who don't eat nuts and they
drink water teas coffee good news a lot
of antioxidants and coffee and then a
little bit of wine those are the four
beverages soda pops were largely unknown
to Blue Zone longevity all-stars the
maximum average life expectancy for
people living in America today is about
90 so that essentially means if we can
avoid all the avoidable diseases like
many cancers most heart disease many
sources of dimensioned diabetes the
average person can reach about age 90
and in Costa Rica they're doing it at a
rate two and a half times better than
we're doing in the United States with
115th EML we spent on health care
you